welcome to this video playing the M soft
soft rain soft rain from Costa Rica so
they'll name in them no ok so hips
playing the london system against the
Kings Indian yeah there are many
possible setups I'm going from Reggie
style set up with a double fianchetto
quite a solid way to play ok so he's not
content with them playing c3 and those
kind of summer passive moves came I'm
going for him isolated Queens bone
hoping to to show that the bishop on f4
and poor knowledge free are not the best
possible moves maybe maybe this is
something to try okay let's um complete
development of the night I think you
should go to c6 and he's so also
completing development if I take on see
form i always need to reckon with d5 I
don't think it is particularly
problematic here but still hmm ok let's
take
in fact some if I'm I this participation
is hanging on c4 in a way now thinking
about 94 but you can take on f7 I don't
really want that okay the 95 next in
this position it's coming with the
temple on the bishop forever what I'm
just seeing as if he takes at the end
there some probably seven hanging knight
takes Bishop takes rook c8 Quincy edge
where work takes in seven some annoying
instead he's just giving away a form
white resonant very sudden end of this
game yeah i was thinking can what what
about 35 yeah i should i should probably
take with the queen but the still is
having hanging I mean something like
that it's not clear
and maybe I can take deform because of
the maid idea but it's looking at looks
that looks a bit shaky those two pieces
yeah maybe night f5 and 95 is ok but
maybe I should need some prep here like
this and then 95 with a normal isolated
queen for one position this is probably
even worse maybe this one hard but but
does this v8 yeah I didn't plan all this
so I'm bit too bit shaky this position I
probably shouldn't have played 95 but if
I wouldn't have played at him he
wouldn't have blundered the bishop all
right very very quick game not a real
game what I could point out though that
this kind of setup oops just too much
this double fianchetto set up here with
the v6 is a good way to play against the
london system i made a video series how
to combat the Sun opening with Bishop f4
and this is one of the setups that can
be recommended very often white plays in
this this manner and this is quite
flexible the bishops are an icy placed
black can prepare you five or sometimes
go for the beatport push takes a while
but this is quite ok not shade of a
problem for black but usually you don't
win in like 12 move something unless the
opponent gives you peace ok thanks for
watching